what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone did we just become best
friends
yep
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of
unwaxed with your favorite sisters
sophia
and sistine still lounge sophia and i
for a long time uh
tried to harmonize and we thought we
were really good at harmonizing
you know rewind it it's always after a
night out
we're in the car it's probably 2 am
headed home right
randomly and we think that we can sing
every time do you want to just try right
now
absolutely not you want me to forget i'm
not
i'll tell you why i'm one of those
people that think that they're a good
singer until they hear it back
and it's actually nails on a chalkboard
well i don't yeah
sing pretty well i i can kind of hold
you i was way better
before i used to sing i don't know if
anyone knew that side note
but now i can't really hold anything i
try to just be good at karaoke i think
that's my goal now is
just hold a tune when you're doing
karaoke what's your go-to karaoke song i
think we had this combo before
we'll say it again i don't know okay
okay um what was my code 2 karaoke song
so she had this convo but can you no i i
do i would say uh why why am i
forgetting
bust a move that's not singing that's
rapping the whole time yeah but you
gotta have to you have to start with an
impressive one
or you kind of go in with the lady gaga
shallow
you know that's hard i don't know yeah i
don't know where i'm going with this
my brain is off right now i can tell
yeah i don't know why i just because you
didn't sleep last night
yeah i did not sleep last night oh yeah
can i actually say this really quick
okay so last night um
i i felt pretty tired i went to bed
probably around 10 30 and then i was
like you know obviously get like an
extra kick i'm just gonna take some
melatonin right
so i'm waiting waiting waiting by 11
o'clock
it hits and i fall asleep and i had the
worst nightmare ever
just horrible i had multiple people
stalking me
but they were all demons and i just felt
like i couldn't get out of anything
and i just woke up sweating and i was
like oh my god that was horrible and it
felt so long
i look at my clock it says 12 30
a.m an hour passed
not even is there anything worse than
when you think it's
oh it's going to be 4 30 in the morning
and it's fully just 11. well that's why
i thought i woke up i was like okay
if it's 4 30 in the morning i'm fine
with that
because i can whenever i'll fall back
and sleep for another two hours i'll
wake up but
i had another six hours sleep and i
could not go back to sleep i just kept
falling asleep waking up falling
and every time i closed my eyes it was
scary oh
yeah it was just not fun last night so
i'll start talking man
please i'll take over please it's okay
so thank you
um we are headed back to la
we're we're going to say bon voyage to
florida it's been a wonderful few months
it's actually kind of crazy when i look
back and
think that i've been living here for
over four months
yeah that's a long time i don't think
we've ever lived somewhere else for that
long
right so i'm very excited to go back to
la so right after this episode we're
about to
build some boxes and pack our life back
up
and begin the next chapter which is
excited
to go back to l.a yeah very excited
but a little bit nervous because this
next chapter is sophia and i
moving in together either this is a
hallelujah
or this is a dun dun dun
so i don't really know how to feel
um i'm excited i
okay i feel like we should have more
energy
about living together i'm excited you
know it's
a positive thing but and we have been
indirectly living with each other so we
kind of know
ish what to expect i think it's gonna be
different not having
parents around it's gonna be amazing but
you know this is what i said i'm a big
i'm a big advocate in a good pros and
cons list
you know i love you just seeing the good
in things
the bad of things weighing out my
options sound like me
do i yeah you sound very analytical well
maybe i am in my room alone at night oh
you're turning into me and you're in
your room alone at night let's not go
that far
i um told sophia and i said
you know what let's just before we take
this big step
let's just write a little pros and cons
list
about living with each other and perhaps
let's read it aloud on the podcast so we
have brought in
our pros and cons list of living with
each other and we're going to hear it
for the first time
right now yeah do you want to start sure
should we start with your pros yeah okay
these are the pros
from sistine's point of view about
living with sophia
yeah pro number one
she'll always make the coffee in the
morning and you make
bomb coffee thank you every single day i
make the family copy
so that's a problem i turn it on at
seven a.m another pro
is you won't forget to lock the doors at
night no because you're very
um suspicious of bad things yeah things
coming in our home
um we can watch anime together that's
fun
oh my gosh yeah um we'll be able to work
together you know get more [ __ ] done
because we're in close quarters true
you're single
i'm single we're in a single fun times
yeah we're going to be like
little night stalkers we are going to be
hurricanes
yes yes um we both like listening
to sad music that makes us sadder so we
can just blast that in the apartment i
told cesino the other day i played a
playlist called crying in my bathroom
shower or something that sounded like
yours not your playlist she has a
playlist called
crying in the shower doesn't count but i
just started crying doing my makeup for
no reason
was not sad about anything see and uh
we'll never run out of almond butter or
granola
absolutely not because sophia i'm pretty
sure 20
of her body mass is made up of almond
butter and granola yeah the doctor told
me that i probably should
cut down the almond butter i eat but she
won't i won't do you want to hear your
cons
what should we do your i'll say my
friends you do your approach okay god
i only wrote four so i wrote an in-house
workout partner
will always keep each other motivated so
because we both love to go to the gym
and we'll always like and we kind of
like the same workout i wrote drinking
buddy
i feel like sistine is like me where
probably on a wednesday if we're
stressed out we'll be like let's go to a
bar
get just a glass of wine sure right um
we can watch anime together i wrote that
too
how cute same page oh my gosh um
and i said she can also make me a lot of
type of soups
like she's good at making soup so we'll
always have some soup in the
refrigerator
okay yes those that's it yeah and i was
gonna write like
work together i was gonna say in-house
best friend yeah
oh oh i also was gonna add that you i
have my in-house
fashion stylist with me because if i
don't have a good al financial reseller
so my list is
we can drink together and i can make you
soup no
i literally said exactly the same thing
you said you said i have always almond
butter and i lock the door
that's important stuff yeah so is soup
and working out
all right let's do the cons okay let's
do the cons um
don't hate me no i won't here's sophia's
cons
there will be no fun snacks in the
apartment because she is very healthy
so forget about i like beet chips
we'll get there and kale chips so no
pirate booty
no yeah right
another con you wake up at 7am and you
blast reality
tv dating shows extremely loud therefore
waking me up don't read the wall street
journal temptation island gets their
brain stimulated
wake up screaming that's the perfect one
so she's up at the ass crocodile don't
love that another one
your migraines make you no fun sorry all
you what
that's not my control yeah but you just
sit in the dark
all day and i'm like can we play outside
oh there's another one positive in-house
nurse if i have a migraine she has to
take care of you see that's my con
okay great um you're a terrible driver
so i'll have to do all of the driving
chauffeur right this is not looking
great for me okay
um another con this one really bothers
me
when you eat you crunch really loud i
like textured food
who likes like slime food like jello no
but so what are you eating i'll hear
sophia in her room eating beet chips
crunching like a little rabbit on them
well beet chips kind of taste stale but
i still like them
another one oh gosh how many did you
make for me
you're so another one
she eats all the gum she eats all the
gum if you buy
a car pack a 60 gum she'll eat nine
pieces at one time
it's just my anxiety i need to just chew
for a hot second nine
yeah nine pieces no i i've reduced it to
four
i've reduced it four so we're going to
have to we'll have to over
supply yeah i did say whenever we had
that talk what would be my strange
addiction it would be gum
yep yep still probably would be and
lastly
you are too nice in the morning
and i know people are like okay that's a
good thing
but i don't like to be disturbed until
my brain is
awake which normally takes about two
hours to wake up
and you're just too happy-go-lucky
chipper bouncing off the walls and that
energy is just not
not aligning the mind those are my cons
okay
fair enough fair enough i give it to you
okay
these are my four for you going off what
you just said i wrote
is the meanest morning person ever
sistine cannot be ruder in the morning
i'll
say to her i literally i say hi
good morning and she doesn't say one
word
[Laughter]
she growls and she's had her coffee
everything
just and i ask what's wrong and then she
gets mad if i ask her what's wrong
and apparently it's just because just
don't talk to me she's just not awake
yet
um two if we have an argument
i will be like a statue and almost
unemotional about it and then you will
be too emotional and then we'll just get
so it will just like blow up i don't
agree you think you're a statue when we
fight
i think when we get so emotional no you
get emotional and then i'll shut down be
like what's wrong
no i don't think you do yeah you we
literally just had that last night
and you were popping off like a firework
and then i stopped
because you were wrong
guys boys i'm never wrong um okay
well three will hog the narrow sleep and
so she'll fall asleep at like 9
30 but then if there's no nerve sleep
she'll claim that she has
insomnia so sistine has a melatonin
issue
um with i take gummies occasionally but
she drinks
narrow sleep which is a melatonin drink
i wouldn't say it's an issue just more
of an
issue it's every single night it's this
orange bottle the helper falls like and
now it's just psychological now she just
can't fall asleep without the bottle i'd
say
it's more of a hobby a lifestyle if you
will
i think if my body is part almond butter
her body's part narrow sleep
i swear if i like suck a straw on her
right now
and taste into your blood
i don't know where you going with that
all right continued
all right four we'll only eat soup
you eat a lot of soup all the time you
always want soup you like the carrot
ginger
you like the sodium you like the white
bean soup you like the tomato bisque
hold on you liked me a minute ago
for making soup and now it's on your
cons list
make up your mind you said you like to
eat healthy with me but then i also
don't have a lot of healthy snacks just
like you make a lot of soup great
but then you just eat soup it's kind of
annoying
i'm trying to think about other cons i
need more cons for you do i
oh con we don't have the same
we're not the same size so i can't
borrow her clothes like i'm borrowed
scarlett's clothes i can't borrow your
clothes you still borrow my clothes
barely i can't fit in your jeans so
kahn can't use her closet also khan
bigger feet than me
all right i can't use her shoes okay
what else
anything else con we look like twins so
we'll have to tell everyone we're not
twins every single time we go out
the con everyone thinks i'm older than
you yeah
pro i hate that sistine looks older than
me everyone thinks i'm older i don't
know why
i know at least everyone doesn't think
you're well i was your mom is my mom
everyone thinks our mom is our sister so
yeah yeah fair enough fair enough but
you know i think overall
it actually is going to be very very fun
we've been looking forward to this for a
while we have the same
exact style for how we're going to live
we know the same area we want to live in
um i want our apartment to be so quirky
so quirky
i want it to look like new girl i want
this
like i want it to be a green sofa yeah
and a melting clock on the wall
and a bunch of weird figurines i just
wanted to look
weird and fun i want people to walk in
and be like this
is their part like no one else would
have this apartment except
who let them design this apartment this
they look like a struggling artist
they're just gonna be [ __ ] everywhere
it looks like blue's clue's house on
crap
you know i i i could have called you out
today on this episode did i do something
and uh this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
all right well i love this [ __ ] okay so
transitioning now
we have the beautiful katie austin she
is a fitness content creator has her own
podcast
she's super cool she went to sc with me
fight on and she is here to share
her tips and tricks this summer she
talks about her experience with
si and we get into boy talk and cece
shares us a little story about her
birthday
and boys what does that mean stay tuned
this gorgeous girl is a fitness
instructor sharing her daily workouts
and healthy recipes i've tried a few
um content creator the host of her brand
new podcast austin f
she just shot with sports illustrated
for the first time and she has over 300
thousand on instagram
she's killing it and we are so excited
to have her on this is katie
yay katie hi guys thanks for that intro
by the way
i know don't you love a good intro sofia
and i missed writing intros we haven't
written a good intro like that in a
while and we just love having females
like you on so thanks for coming on the
show today
thank you guys that was a it was a
really great intro have you interviewed
me every time oh my god of course we
actually i think
the last time um we had victoria garagon
she said the same thing i was like why
don't we just make that your alarm clock
or a ringtone imagine if that's just
your alarm clock every day
that's a really good idea keep me
motivated but also keep me humble
i need to be humble so maybe not i know
if someone taught us like you need to
learn the difference between being cocky
and confident and i feel like that would
make me cocky
yeah yeah i'm a badass sophia and i are
the perfect girls to do that she'll
keep you up and then i'll keep you down
that's true
i'll be like no stay humble yeah we're
ying and yang this is perfect
um let's just jump right into it i would
love to
sort of have your description tell our
listeners sort of what you do
what you're about what your youtube
channel is about and we'll sort of go
from there
yeah a little bit of background on me i
went to usc i was a division one athlete
at usc i'm from virginia i played
lacrosse my entire life and into college
so
um i studied sports broadcast and i kind
of combined my love for athletics and
fitness with my sports uh
background with sports broadcasting at
the same time
and started doing youtube videos
teaching workouts online and following
my mom's fitness footsteps
i actually did my first workout video
when i was like seven years old
which was crazy yeah i've already had a
tv show for 26 years
wow in her footsteps and she's kind of
like a legend in the fitness industry so
following in her fitness footsteps now i
have my own app my own tv show
and uh i do sports hosting also on the
side i mean that's incredible you're
doing it all
and it's just it's so cool because
sophia and i also have
you know a mom that was so successful in
her industry and we even were
wanting to dabble into it but it was
honestly too hard for us so it's really
cool that
you have um a figure above you that you
can sort of just
she's your mentor and your mom all in
one so
i would love to know about this
seven-year-old fitness story i would
love to start there
um kind of young but love it
love it working young yes very young
and i'm sure you guys also deal with
this too like the pressure of
being in a very successful family and
following in your parents footsteps
it's definitely a lot of pressure and it
can
open some doors but it won't push you
through the doors you still have to work
really hard yourself
absolutely and for me um you know i
started at seven years old but i never
saw it as a career like
instagram youtube like wasn't the thing
obviously when i'm like like 14 years
old
so it wasn't until after i graduated
from usc that i like really thought it
could be a career
because of instagram to be honest and i
hate the word influencer but like that's
but it's true are you okay i mean the
things that we've gone just from our
instagram alone
has like been able to pay off a lot of
things and being an influencer is a
full-time job i mean
running the number of accounts you said
you had an app a youtube your instagram
i mean you're constantly
creating content that is a full-time
people realize like make fun of the name
influencer but that's a lot of work
mm-hmm
a lot of it yes i hate when people make
fun of it because
they don't realize what goes into it
it's not just posting a pretty photo on
instagram
um like you guys you know it's beyond
that it's a
personal brand and it's an online
program i run my customer service my app
my pinterest youtube facebook ads uh i
have you know my talk show i booked the
guest like there's so many things that
go
into it that people don't realize and so
um i think
that's the that's kind of the beauty of
it though also is is growing online and
doing it fully self-employed the freedom
of it is so amazing and
you have to push yourself to do it too
no one else you don't have a boss so no
one's telling you what to do you have to
actually push yourself which is actually
really freaking hard like you guys know
no it totally is and i mean we call i
like to call ourselves an entrepreneurs
because you're basically running your
own brand no one else is going to tell
you
actually no one else is going to help
you and you realize the more things you
do
the more opportunities you're going to
get so if you're kind of lagging on one
area
that person might not notice so you have
to keep it up 24 7 and then you're also
someone that people follow and look up
to and i know for
us like sometimes that can feel like
some pressure because we always want to
look
presentable perfect like our bodies are
well we're healthy and
i know that you probably probably feel
that as well just because that's your
image it's like you're a fitness girl
you're healthy you're fun it's
constant positivity do you ever feel
like that's can get like caught up to
you and feel pressure
for sure i think for the first few years
of the fitness industry i try to be like
this perfect like i work out six days a
week
i eat salad and now i've completely
switched my brand because i realize
that that type of posting makes someone
else feel really bad about what they're
not doing
right so when i realized that i was like
wait a second i'm real
i drink a lot of tequila and i ate a
breakfast
and i talked about my mental health i
have anxiety i did a post on it like two
days ago i posted my breakfast burrito
this morning and
the more vulnerable i've been online i
have received
like so much love from that and girls
realizing like they're not alone and i
always like
try to tell my followers exactly like
when i'm working out and when i'm not
working out
because i need them to know just because
i'm a fitness trainer doesn't mean i'm
working out all the time at all and you
can have a really well
balanced realistic life i mean you just
said tequila breakfast burritos and
anxiety and
that's that's that's me in a nutshell
basically but it's true because
i know that sometimes when i look at
these influencers that are fitness girls
and they show what they eat in a day or
like how much they work out i'm like oh
my god i'm really lagging on some of
these things
and it's nice to finally see that even
you're just being honest about it you're
like i can still eat healthy but i can
have a breakfast burrito i can still
feel fit and not work out every day like
six days a week and actually sistine
didn't you have a question about that
because you said that
she would probably help you with this
sophia and i
are so into fitness i mean we're working
out a lot and
sometimes i honestly think we work out
too much yeah
for example i need your help i probably
work out
six days a week yeah minimum maybe seven
days a week
and i eat pretty healthy i'll do 80 20
you know i will have a drink or two
or four during the weekends and you know
lifestyle is really good
but i don't see an improvement and i
don't see
uh progression in my body so i'm like
kind of just stuck
a digression in my body so i'm kind of
just stuck in this middle
ground is it like my diet should i work
out less
i mean what do you sort of recommend yes
so by the way you look freaking amazing
so thanks i'm wearing like a little
boy's uniform
thank you what i will say if anyone else
is feeling this way as well like switch
up your routine i don't know if you're
doing the same thing
six days a week but your body definitely
needs rest off of those like high
intensity strength training workouts
so you want to mix in like for me i do
like pilates one day and then i do bar
and then i also do a walk and then i do
my high intensity training and i do
strength training
so i mix it up every single day um and
that's what works for me
i don't know your diet but 80 20 sounds
amazing
um sorry that was my phone
um oh um so i mean your diet sounds
really great
at the same time though just switching
up that uh switching up that workout
routine i think will really really
really help for sure okay yeah i agree
because i sometimes
you know when you're just doing the same
thing over and over and then you just
start dreading working out
i'm starting to sort of dread i
understand your why why are you working
out are you trying to attain a goal
and or is it to something like
aesthetically pleasing to lose weight or
is it to get a six-pack like what's your
why
for me i truly work out to feel more
confident to
help my anxiety to sleep better for my
heart and my health reasons and so
that's why i work out so i think
if you're anywhere starting your journey
or like you you guys work out a ton it's
like understanding that why you want to
exercise
that's true i think sometimes we just
sophia and i are funny we say we work
out
just preparing for that moment you never
know when you know
that beach day is going to sneak up on
you or the girl's throwing a danger
we're always right we're dating ssi
comes calling yes
speaking that actually happened though
it actually happened okay i was going to
ask you how did that happen because you
just shot with us
i saw her photos like are you kidding me
just shut up katie chefs amazing and you
were right you were body ready
you were ready so how did that even come
up
okay so i actually auditioned for sports
illustrated swimsuit back in 2017
didn't get it waited a few years and i
decided
last july to audition so almost a
freaking year wow
i put out my tape in august forgot about
it
completely just like four weeks before
our shoot and we're like hey you got it
you're shooting
and meanwhile i'm like not prepared at
all like i literally was like
eating drinking so much i felt like
since like thanksgiving like oh my god
just totally forgot about it was so
shocked that i got it
and then what really helped me was um i
gave up alcohol for 30 days which if you
know me is freaking impossible
if you know us that's impossible i think
we like it we're like okay
one day it's not bad if we break it no
it's it's impossible it's hard
it was i think what helps me most like
just
like not i didn't want to lose weight it
wasn't that because s i like
it doesn't want you to lose weight they
wanted me exactly how i was that's for
sure but at the same time i just wanted
to go into it feeling my best self and
alcohol just like
can make me more anxious and make me
kind of puffy so giving up alcohol for
30 days was one of the best things ever
done
did you see any body changes did you see
yourself actually like your skin was
probably more glowing or you didn't feel
as like tired in the morning or what was
the benefits from just all of that
i had way better skin my skin cleared up
like crazy you guys
don't tell me which i know i don't that
makes me so sad
ear earmuffs way more energy
like i seriously felt like so energized
every day
no anxiety i lost i want to say like
anywhere between like
five to eight pounds in like 20 days
which was like insane
oh and then you think about it how we
drink and i feel like maybe you're like
this too we're not like very
super super sweet margarita type we like
like putting
nice like limes and fries we like to
keep our cocktails like
healthy as much as we can because we
like to taste the tequila you probably
like that as well
same same i'm like a skinny margarita
girl i don't mind tequila soda like
i i'm so for healthy drinks and so that
was the craziest part to me but at the
same time
i started drinking again over the
weekend and i'm like okay i started at
11 a.m on saturday and went to
2 a.m and i had probably drink every
hour i'm like
that alone is 2 000 calories and exposed
to metabolism
so you're like i have to catch up for
everything i missed out on 30 days
but you had a good time i bet i was in
vegas
there we go there you go can't take that
back
okay so quitting alcohol i did a sober
october one time
it was hard but it was honestly the best
thing ever i felt all of those things as
well so maybe um
we stopped drinking alcohol and then s i
will come knocking at our door i know
no no live your life also summer's
coming up
don't give up alcohol speaking of summer
that was great
yeah honestly helping us so much
sophie and i uh a few episodes back
we're talking about how we're trying to
get into hot girl summer see the only
thing i could come up with was shaving
my legs more
but we want to talk about you know
getting our bikini body ready
you know feeling our best self mentally
physically because
we're opening up now yeah and like
health is wealth so if our minds right
our sort of our body feels right so what
are you doing to prepare
for summer 2021 honestly
nothing i know that sounds like really
you know
not true whatever you can look at my
fitness page and be like she's
definitely preparing for summer and
stuff but i'm not at all i think it's
all a mindset
uh you hear it all the time it's really
cliche but you are already bikini body
ready you don't need to
lose any weight plus your worth is not
validated on your on your weight you're
not going to be
any happier if you lose 5 to 10 pounds i
promise you that confidence will come
from within
and so i love hot girl summer but not
for like losing weight or fitness
reasons or
getting hot physically it's all a
mindset you're totally right
i don't know see no one puts this
pressure on me i think sort of being on
instagram and
all i'm doing is just seeing girls with
stunning
hourglass figures thinking okay this is
real
and i won't be confident enough to post
a bathing suit of myself unless i know
that my waist is that snatched and my
hips naturally go out that wide
even though they do no but they do no
one's body look
no but no one's body looks that way you
know it is phase two and
let's keep it real so i think that
you're so right when
you're not doing anything and that's
something i should start doing because
this pressure that's always
i mean we talk about it we talk about
all the time we i mean we make jokes
about hot girl summer like i'm gonna put
probably less heat on my hair so i don't
fry my hair up
by the time like june comes around but
it's really just like it's really a
mentality thing that we put on ourselves
for no reason
yeah and i kind of love that you
advocate totally against that you're
like actually i'm doing nothing and
you're keeping it unwaxed and that's
what we love to do on this show
i just want like the listeners if
they're listening right now to
understand like
you two are just insanely beautiful than
the best bodies and even you guys
compare yourselves and i compare myself
to other girls
and we constantly online
are just you know looking at other
people's bodies and thinking like wow i
wish i don't have that
so focusing on what you do have and all
your strengths and positive things and
like practicing gratitude is so
important
and knowing even like who you think is
your epitome of beautiful
also can feel insecure and not confident
sometimes i was just with a lot of
sports losers models and trust me
like the most beautiful girls in the
world like in quotes like whatever
beauty means to anyone
in the world but at the same time like
they have down times they have those
days they have not the most confident
selves and so
um anyone listening to that like you're
not alone in that well thank you so much
for trying that and that's such a sweet
compliment
um i would love to sort of know how you
even got this mindset
right you know because i think this
isn't something that people just
inherently have no it's a practice right
you have to how do you remind yourself
so how did you learn
to do that took a long freaking time i
was so insecure as a teenager like
so so insecure all right i was insecure
because i was lifting so much and i
hated my body i was eating
so much and lifting and i was just not
i just didn't love my body at all so it
takes years and i
hate the word journey because i think
it's so lame but
self-love is a journey it really is it's
something that you need to practice
every single day
by making sure i'm keeping up with
things that i love to do
like hang out my friends surrounding
myself with good people that
you know make me feel confident and and
not surrounding myself with people who
make me feel um less than and
also making promises to myself that i
will keep so like giving up alcohol
i told myself i'm gonna give up alcohol
for 25 days and when i got to like the
27th day
i was like i made a promise to myself i
feel more connected i can do this and so
when you make those promises and you
keep them
you'll gain self-love i mean i honestly
like just love to work out because
that's how i get the confidence and
trust me i'm not confident every single
day but um i
am pretty happy with where i'm at right
now for sure oh that's awesome awesome
i would love to sort of touch on you
know we
don't like to diet we never have
restricted ourselves from foods or
anything yeah but i do want to touch on
the fact that
you were able to stick with something
and and try and
execute it successfully for example i
tried being a pescetarian
for an entire year and it i stuck with
it i couldn't believe i did it and it
worked i loved the way my body looked
but then you know i
sort of lacked that iron i wasn't taking
any pills and i started
depleting a little bit getting really
tired are you on any sort of
you know vegan diet or vegetarian diet
or have you tried any of them
no no i will never i could never it's
not really
for me and if i even tell myself like
hey you're gonna try to go vegetarian
for
a few months like i know i can't do that
so i'm just setting myself up for
failure
and then i'll feel less confident uh if
i do not
complete that promise and so never make
goals that are just unattainable
obviously try new things because your
body might be wanting something
and obviously whole30 could be good for
you sometimes but if it's unrealistic
for you then don't freaking do it i
don't know yeah i feel like if you
should if you're going to make a
commitment to yourself make sure it's a
positive one because i know that any
time i
mess up i put i'm like oh [ __ ] i had
bread i don't know that was when i was
like really stupid but
whenever i would get mad about that i'd
really be hard on myself and i feel like
that's what causes a snowball of
okay if i did it like i guess i just
[ __ ] up my whole thing and it just
gets worse and worse and worse and
so if you're gonna choose i don't even
think you should ever diet but if you're
to choose a certain like outcome make
sure it's one that
you can actually manage and you feel
like okay
i can do this it's easy it's maybe start
with something small
and then you can go to something like a
bit harder or bigger like cutting
alcohol because that is not
easy for everybody especially if you're
trying to be social and some people get
nervous without drinking when they're
out but i feel like that's a good way to
start about it
right would you say just like a little
something every day
for sure i would never do a juice
cleanse though screw that i did that one
time dude
no i can't there's so many places in la
that have juice cleansing we lived on
the toilet
oh sorry i lived on like having just an
upset stomach and bloating
for i don't know it is not good for you
and it strips all the nutrients like
it's better to have fruit and vegetables
either raw
or cooked rather than you know juicing
them it just it's just not worth it
oh i could not so actually i wanted to
switch into
um because i saw i was saying assistant
i don't know if this is bad or good
that we're going to i know we said not
like hot girl summer but hot girl summer
with
no boyfriend and we're super single and
i know that you have a boyfriend
hello so how do you love the time i want
to talk about how long you guys been
dating where'd you guys meet
okay it's it's still new it's like
almost eight months so it's not like
that's not like that was short though i
was yeah
she goes it's new i'm like that's a
long-term relationship it's quarantine
the longest relationship we have is
probably like a month yeah
maybe it is really hard in quarantine to
meet someone i was also single for like
two and a half years and so
um i know what it's like to be single
and
my advice is to embrace it um
if i was still single i would just tell
myself to do everything
are you guys shaking your head you said
yes no we're so bored
you're like it's been two years what am
i trying to embrace
you never know if you are going to meet
that boyfriend or that person the next
freaking day
and if that doesn't scare you to live it
up right now then i don't know what will
because
i literally was like oh my gosh i'm so
single whatever for a year and then i
was like okay
i don't know when that person's gonna
come and so live every single day
like i'm never gonna be single again and
it helped my mindset i focused on myself
i focused on my career it was the first
time in my life
that i was never looking for a boyfriend
and that's when i met him
and so i mean obviously everything
happens to a reason you have to put
yourself out there
no it's at the same time like once
you're so happy with yourself and being
alone
then you can be ready did you meet this
guy in l.a because
i mean is there any more pickings in l.a
i will say this um you also have to
choose the right type of guys
i was going after guys on like raya who
were horrific
and this guy don't even get a starter
regular nine to five finance dude
doesn't do instagram
amazing can i say perfect when he
doesn't have an instagram
you hit the lottery well he probably has
an instagram
wait did you see he has an instagram he
has like 500 followers and it's probably
doesn't feel like one instagram model
i'm like yes
it's for friends and family and it's
private you won
that's the brightest kind of guy it is
did you just meet him like out at a
social event
uh a mutual friend actually like i met i
connected with him on dating app
i didn't reply to him on a dating app
because i just like didn't do first
dates i was like over it
and then i he asked me out on the dating
app i didn't reply
he found my instagram and how to connect
us and i bailed on him an hour before
our first date
got drunk later shut up wait wait
he failed a week later i made him i got
drunk and i was like
hey i'm in venice at the waterfront i
was with like six girlfriends he came
alone
and i was a [ __ ] show and he passed the
test
i love it wait i love it okay so that's
the thing we always say we have like
alcohol guilt sometimes when we
we go out and sometimes we feel the next
day or how we behave like
we're not look when we drink we're
actually fun we're not like sloppy or
anything
but when we meet a guy we talk to him we
always feel embarrassed the next like oh
god i probably looked stupid
but that's when you know he's a good guy
and you can wake up and go you know what
he actually passed us because i didn't
feel awkward about it like he liked it
he like liked your extra self and like
that you like to probably dance or like
socialize with friends and be out and
enjoy a good time
totally that over freaking sucks i've
been there done that and i've definitely
gotten way too drunk and ruined it
sometimes but at the same time
a good guy will and it's never as bad as
you think it is by the way like
you probably never said something too
out there um
and so a good guy will probably still
stay and talk to you the next day yeah
we'll see we're going to see
well we're we tend to not you know we
tend to not
pick good guys we pick like
yeah yeah we're we're trying we're
trying but you know if he has any
friends i feel like that's the way
especially in quarantine people are
getting set up that's just the way you
meet people
yeah friends through friends i mean if
you got any guys
but also i do think this you guys are
still so young
that you're going after the wrong guy
like for me when i was you know
20 to 25 i was definitely going after
the f boy the guy who's not as like nice
and stuff
but once you're so funny they're so much
fun
that you want them because they don't
want you
exactly i love toxic energy exactly and
once you like grow out of that stage
you'll like go for the guy who's
actually worth it
right that's so true okay so was there
ever a second date a proper second date
um no i invited him to my birthday party
in palm springs and he
stayed at my parents house i'm literally
the second time i feel like
you've met boys like consecutively on
her sort of
it kind of happens funny that way i
don't know why
every year on my birthday either
it's such a good i'm sorry it's your
birthday my birthday is coming up
june 27th and i don't know why but the
last
three years coincidentally i'm either
meeting a new guy or kissing a stranger
every single year on her birthday she
has
but they end up being good guys no they
end up actually dating
so okay i'm gonna follow up with you on
june 28th and ask you oh by the way
there's
there's gonna be someone oh yeah just
don't worry she already has a line up
but no the
there was one it's not like that
oh wait no yeah but wait no there was
one that was last year speaking of raya
that was so funny
she met one two i think it was right
before like
restaurants were shut down it was the
day before it was day before not in l.a
we we i think this was like the last
time we ever thought raya was ever gonna
work was because she met someone from
ryan he came
to her birthday she didn't me we i was
with her so we were of course had
tequila and we go you know what
screw it invite him we don't know what
he looks like we don't know who he is
like just
let me tell you i was expecting
nev from catfish to show up because your
girl got catfished
bad really very bad instagram beforehand
no see that's my problem i don't
investigate the guy
i investigate sophia is like the cia and
i will literally
date ted bundy and not know like i will
just go into a blind i
i think investigating is really good but
someone like my boyfriend
was i wasn't able to investigate him
yeah so sometimes you do have to take
those risks but meet him in a public
place
never yeah but actually i can't wait you
do have to take those risks sometimes
because i would have never i literally
blew my boyfriend now off
first date because i saw two photos of
him on a dating profile with 17 other
dudes in the photo and i was like
who the hell are you i don't care and so
you do have to take a risk
yeah that's true and i feel like the
guys i've actually have not looked up on
and or i couldn't
have been better off because i've like
not had this preconceived notion in my
brain
or i feel like it's just maybe maybe the
energy in the world is telling me to
stop looking into people and just like
get along with them naturally and chill
out
but my virgo crazy brain can't do that
she's just a
bit of a control freak i'm not just a
little i mean which is so easy if
they're public on instagram
you can literally go to their sister's
cousin's you know wedding
and see what they were who they were
doing in 2017. oh my god you can go onto
their mom's thing see what they look
like
middle school no i don't want to know i
don't want to know
i i don't think i want to know but i
just end up getting bored and just start
like going fold in
i want to go back to your relationship
what was the most
do you do romantic things for your man
or does he mostly do the romantic things
for you
he is a very romantic person but it's
definitely me cooking for him a lot like
i would say the most
romantic thing that i do is like meal
prep for him
oh i love him honestly
i would love love meal prepping yeah
what do you meal prep
what is that i cook him i sound so lame
right now and
but i promise i do so i do wear the
pants in the relationship it's something
that i love to do
um i make him some cauliflower rice and
a lot of
sheep veggies which like i just put so
much zucchini broccoli cauliflower
onions on a pan like a cookie sheet
i bake them and then i also make him
like ground turkey salmon or chicken
that's um see i stock her food thing
like you make such good food and i need
we need to start doing that because we
are starting to get into cooking and i
feel like we need to start learning how
to meal prep
you're that sounds unreal yeah and that
is love i'm sorry
meal prep is love it is
food is the way to someone's heart wait
so you obviously know how to cook kind
of well then
yes i love to cook honestly cooking is
my form of like meditation and therapy
it's like where i feel most calm and
like trying out new recipes
and also um they they're not anything
too crazy by the way like i'm my recipes
are really basic
really easy and so i think uh when you
cook healthy
it can be a really easy it could take 10
minutes and it could be delicious and i
think a lot of times
people think cooking healthy can be
really boring but it doesn't happen no
we love to cook healthy and sophia and i
have been trying to hook
more it hasn't been successful because i
think that we're trying to shoot way
above our bracket of
our capabilities yeah so we're gonna
actually cook dinner for the family
tonight what do you recommend it would
be just like
easy recipe that i can just whip up
a good family recipe um it's it's not
very quick though
but my family loves my zucchini lasagna
you take
thin slices of zucchini and you cut it
down the middle straight
through and then you put so you make the
zucchini
just like you would the pasta yeah and
then you put
the olive oil tomato sauce you could put
other vegetables inside like some onions
or
mushrooms so freaking good okay i'm
gonna go on do you have it on your
instagram page yeah
okay perfect i'm gonna definitely use
that's perfect we can just do that easy
that sounds unreal katie thank you
so so so so much for coming on this was
so much fun
honestly like i've had i've been wanting
to have you on
ever since i have i was like i knew her
from sc but like not super well so fight
on
and i just have seen you groan so much
and i'm really happy that you shared all
these tips and tricks with everybody
i know you've built such a great empire
and if you guys aren't already following
katie you must please tell them all of
your profiles your youtube your
instagram where they can find you
i am at katie austin on almost
everything and then the katie austin app
for all my follow along in-home workouts
by the way you guys are amazing i feel
like i i want to like go out with you
guys and take a shower tequila with you
guys and we're coming back for the next
three hours we're coming back to l.a
soon so we'll definitely do that oh my
god that sounds
so much fun thank you so much for coming
on the show today
thank you guys thank you bye
from all of us here at the show thanks
for staying on wax
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts at sophia stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at unwaxed podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week